un peu plus de cinquante mille mètres
cubes d'eau par an pour un nouvel apport
de 100 litres d'eau par jour dans les
bassins 600 mètres cubes d'eau pour le
bassin sportif 300 pour le bassin
ludique et 30 mètres cubes d'eau pour le
bassin des toboggans le centre aquatique
du lac de montigny le bretonneux fête
cette semaine ses dix ans d'existence en
grande pompe l'eau des bassins et rentre
dans un circuit dans un supplice
filtration à passe dans un espèce de
gros réservoirs qu'on peut voir derrière
nous et dans ses réservoirs il y à du
sable et au contact du sable l'eau et
débarrasser des impuretés ensuite avait
traité avec du chlore et avait réinjecté
dans le bassin l'eau des bassins est ici
traitée au chlore gazeux en fonction du
nombre de personnes présentes dans l'eau
les pompes analyse la quantité de chlore
actif dans les bassins et injectent plus
ou moins de clore en fonction des
besoins
les agents de la piscine rendent compte
deux fois par jour de la propreté de
l'eau l' agence régionale de la santé
inspectent elle l'état de l'eau une fois
par mois on a nos qui est désinfecté
c'est à dire que ne transporte pas de
micro wendel est allé désinfectantes
si une personne vient avec une plaie par
exemple cette clé sera désaffectée par
l'eau de la piscine
les 180 mille mètres cubes de chauffage
au gaz à nu elles permettent une
température de 30 degrés aux abords des
bassins pour une température de 27
degrés dans le bassin sportif et 29 30
degrés pour le bassin ludique près de
300000 personnes fréquentent chaque
année le centre aquatique du lac dont
18% représentée par les groupes
scolaires collèges et lycées de montigny
et voisins le bretonneux et ça fait dix
ans que ça dure